bonjour l'isaf à laon les députés ont
notamment entonné une marseillaise
observé une minute de silence
oui effectivement beaucoup d'émotions
ici à l'assemblée nationale avec cette
séance qui a débuté avec en préambule à
un moment une minute de silence en
hommage à samuel pâtit qui a été
assassiné parce qu'il développe elle
l'esprit critique de futurs citoyens ce
sont les mots de richard ferrand le
président de l'assemblée nationale alors
interrogé sur les actions concrètes
mises en place par le gouvernement pour
lutter contre l'islamisme radical jean
castex le premier ministre a pris la
parole
il a notamment annoncé en que près de
8000 personnes étaient actuellement
faisait actuellement l'objet d'une
surveillance permanente le premier
ministre qui a également tenu à rappeler
que trente deux attentats avaient été
déjoués depuis mai 2017 jean castex qui
promet la dissolution pour toutes les
associations complice avec l'islamisme
radical alors malgré toutes ces annonces
des députés avec qui nous avons parlé
avant cette crise cette séance de
questions au gouvernement nous ont dit
que si il était heureux en deux sets de
cet hommage rendu de cet hommage
national rendu à samuel pâtit regrettait
que le gouvernement ne met pas en place
des actions concrètes je proposais les
écouter mais si on peut se demander ce
qu'ils ont fait depuis trois ans mais
pourquoi n'ont ils pas expulser les
fichiers se radicaliser de nationalité
étrangère pourquoi les mosquées
salafistes sont elles encore ouverte que
s'est il passé depuis trois ans pourquoi
faut-il attendre qu'un professeur de
français la tête tranchée pour réagir
combien faudra-t-il encore pour réagir
moi je crois que ce gouvernement et ceux
qui le précèdent
tous les xavier bertrand les bruno le
maire tous ceux qui ont des complicités
avec l'islam radical devons rendre des
comptes aux français ce qui me désole
c'est que moi depuis 2000 15 depuis
l'attentât de charlie hebdo j'ai proposé
25 mesures précises pour expulser les
fichiers s pour restaurer l'autorité de
l'état valls une cour de sûreté de
l'état pour réduire les flux migratoires
pour assimiler service national
interdiction du port du voile dans les
universités et jamais de réponse est
donc il faut qu'ils aient un ce drame
une abomination pour qu'il y ait le
début de quelques signaux mais ces
signaux sont encore très faibles
il faut que nos démocraties et en
particulier la démocratie française
puisse se réarmer ça veut dire un
réarmement juridique
on a besoin d'un certain nombre de
textes il faut éviter évidemment et vous
me permettrez l'expression un peu
triviale une course à l'échalote et une
surenchère mais mais on a besoin aussi
d' éléments textuels peut-être de
réviser aussi notre constitution
c'est l'objet d'une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle présenté ce lundi au
sénat il faut que les lois de la
république puisse s'appliquer à tous et
sur l'ensemble du territoire
c'est quand même bien la moindre des
choses et ça c'est pas une surenchère
vous l'avez entendu beaucoup d'émotion
mais aussi de la colère auprès des
députés de l'opposition qui ont tenu à
rappeler que la majorité présidentielle
avait systématiquement rejeté les
propositions faites par les groupes
d'opposition alors au delà de ces
questions il y sera aussi question ici à
l'assemblée nationale deux bureaux l'un
des réseaux sociaux dans ce drame qui
s'est déroulé à conflans sainte honorine
il faut rappeler que samuel patty a fait
l'objet d'une véritable cabale d'une
campagne de dénigrement au cours des
semaines qui ont précédé ce drame alors
il sera question de penser à légiférer à
modérer les réseaux sociaux les députés
devraient aussi poser des questions ou
au gouvernement concernant à la
situation des enseignants qui se sentent
démunis abondonner comment faire pour
renforcer par exemple la sécurité dans
les établissements scolaires voilà donc
cette séance se poursuit ici à
l'assemblée nationale et
entièrement consacré à ce drame de
conflans sainte honorine
elle est la femme merci pour toutes ces
précisions